hi emma how are you doing i'm well how
are you i am so good so first of all i
just listened to solar power it's so
good i love the single the album uh
the nail salon is my favorite
you know it's been four years between
albums was that always the plan to take
an extended amount of time off after
melodrama
um it's never really the plan but it's
always what uh sort of ends up happening
with me because i both because i take a
long time to make things but also
because
i like my albums to be really different
from each other and
i need time to grow and change as a
person to be able to come back with
something really different you know so
it ends up being a while but i hope it's
worth it yeah
i felt very happy listening to this
album oh gosh yeah compared to your
previous albums was your experience this
time around very different
yeah i mean the last one in particular
is so sort of angsty and oh sorry and uh
you know
i was dealing with some you know
very classic kind of
late adolescent emotions um whereas this
one i feel like
and it all sort of settled down and i i
felt a bit calmer and more adult and
able to sort of um ask
questions of myself and be introspective
so i feel like that i hope that comes
across with the music
oh it definitely does and what would you
say you wanted to say with this album
well i wanted to communicate to people
uh the
immense impact that the
spending time in the natural world had
had on me um
i
my life has changed because of my
relationship to going outside uh
i was a a bookworm as a kid you know i
didn't really go outside and then i got
given a cell phone and i would just do
that for hours so
uh it's been a big uh change for me to
be able to
you know
spend an hour or so a day outside just
noticing everything
as corny as that sounds
no but it's so important and i think
more than ever especially over this past
year and a half people have really
reassessed what's important in their
lives and what really makes them happy
did that affect this album as well this
past year and a half
you know it kind of didn't which is
weird because it's definitely a
realization that a lot of people had had
in the last year or so that um you know
spending time in nature was sort of a
non-negotiable for their mental health
um
i started writing this in uh
the beginning of 2019 so this is sort of
something that um
yeah it was was was firmly in progress
by the time the pandemic hit so it's
sort of a a coincidence i guess but i
hope that
uh that means that people you know can
relate to it that bit more having having
come to that realization the last year
oh absolutely so stoned at the nail
salon is honestly my favorite part i
love it so much but i want to know who
in your life have the best reaction to
the title of this song
oh my god definitely my mom my mom
laughed for days and was like great now
every time i go and get my nails done
everyone's going to be laughing at me
[Laughter]
very embarrassing on your parents i was
like oh sorry guys
that is so funny so i have to ask when
was the last time you're stoned in the
nail salon
you know it's been a minute but um
yeah i'm trying to think i mean probably
not that long probably like
uh january or something
six months i don't know it is a favorite
activity of mine
i love that so much now i know that you
worked with jack antonoff on this album
but aside from jack
who is your go-to person when it comes
to
knowing that they will be honest with
you with new music
that's a good question honestly i am uh
kind of
uh i don't seek a lot of outside
opinions on music i'm not sure why that
is i think i'm kind of just like
if it's doing it for me i'm my own
harshest critic by far
so if it's getting past me you know it's
probably okay but
yeah like with this album i don't think
i really played it to anyone until it
was almost finished and even then just a
couple of people heard it so i don't
know i'm kind of a freak like that
there's not a
i don't play stuff to people but i think
i played some to my to my little brother
and he uh
he really liked it he's always a good uh
a good gauge of you know
if he thinks something's cool i'm like
okay i've done a good job oh that's
something i love that you had that
relationship with your brother so then
do you get nervous when a new album
comes out or or do you just feel so good
with what you're putting into the world
that it's kind of like let's see what
happens
well i feel really good about it and
just like psyched for people to have it
um but i you know yeah you do get a
little uh
it's sort of vulnerable you know sharing
that much of yourself with people and
and it's also um it stops belonging to
just you so there is sort of that that
moment of processing that but i'm
excited i want i want people to have
this and to live with it so and that's
not so nervous this time i think for
melodrama i was extremely nervous
well that's good to hear because yeah
you have so much to be proud of when it
comes to this album so you've been
nominated for
five grammys one two at this stage in
your life and your career what is
success for you
oh i mean
just if um
[Music]
i don't know it's definitely not so much
a commercial
success or a
a an awards type success but um
if there's
sort of a
cultural consensus that i am
making my best work and that i'm
chopping myself i feel like i'll be
really happy you know you can sort of
feel that as a musician when there's a
lot of good will for something that
you've made so
hopefully that's the vibe with this
album because
i feel that way about it i feel like
i've made with this work so
yeah hopefully people do too
if you weren't a singer songwriter what
do you think you'd be doing
well i
if i was answering this at 16 i would
say like a lawyer or something because i
definitely thought i'd go down that path
but honestly i love food so much it
would not surprise me if i was working
in food somehow
okay listen this question comes directly
from my executive producer who told me
to ask you about your love for onion
rings do you still enjoy reviewing onion
rings online
i do you know every once in a while i um
i'll pop a review up if i eat a
a ring um but
yeah it has been a minute it's been it's
been a minute between rings they won't
lie but uh no i'll always love them it's
kind of a perfect food they're so uh
it's so simple you know you gotta
there's nowhere to hide it's not like a
pop song you can't uh
there's no there's no yeah
no hiding spot at all i love it and it
just brings so much happiness
i know you are heading out on a really
big tour next year 40 plus dates that's
so exciting but after spending so much
time at home what are you gonna miss the
most after you get back out on the road
honestly i think just um
being super available to my family and
friends i think as a
traveling musician you kind of you know
you miss a lot of birthdays and and like
weddings and babies being born and stuff
so uh i'll miss sort of being available
for every last thing but i'll make it
all up to them in my next sort of long
break
oh i love that i know your mom is your
like biggest fan
what does she think of this album
i think she really likes it yeah i
played it to to her dad um a while ago
and you know i'm sure it's like
overwhelming to
uh
like see inside your child's brain
in the way that they they must with
these albums but
yeah i think they were they liked it and
they they were proud and stuck for me
you know
i love that so with you know
so much that has gone on in this world
how are you feeling right now
i feel pretty good i feel pretty calm
pretty centered i'm excited about what's
coming up um
yeah i
i feel good i feel strong confident
i feel as ready to launch into a very
busy year as as a girl can
that's so exciting and you're inspiring
everybody to wear yellow dresses after
solo thank
thank you so much i really appreciate it
you